many viewers have reached out about rent
increases that they are facing yeah
eight news now continues to shed light
on housing issues that many southern
nevadans are facing the i-team's vanessa
murphy is here with more about what's
behind these most recent rent hikes
denise and brian viewers are contacting
us to say their rent is going up by two
to three hundred dollars sometimes even
more the nevada state apartment
association points to supply and demand
demand for apartments has gone up supply
has gone way down executive director
susie vasquez says usually there are
about 10 to 11 000 units available to
rent in clark county now they're 6 800
that's despite 3 600 new apartments
being added over the past year people
continue to move here to nevada from out
of state vasquez estimates about 40
percent are from california she says
when people started working from home
during the kovit 19 pandemic and
realized they may be able to do that
more permanently many moved to nevada
which is more affordable than other
neighboring states
these people from out of state have just
gobbled up all of these new units and so
typically there's more units available
there isn't
it's estimated that the average rent for
an apartment in 2018 was
dollars now it's 1237.
vasquez says if people start moving out
of nevada if for example they can no
longer work from home and have to be
back in their offices in other states
rent prices may stabilize or decrease
okay so what do you do if your rent is
going up and you can't afford it vasquez
says to try to talk to your landlord to
explain your situation she tells me one
solution might be to try to sign a six
month lease to pay part of the increase
and then pay the remainder of the
increase in the next six months denise
that's a pretty good idea you know we do
have some positive news for our viewers
tonight you've been following the story
of a woman who was evicted she lost her
job in the pandemic she was sleeping in
the car with her dogs so many people the
story resonated with them she lost all
her income and you have a nice update on
her story tonight yeah we shared the
story of karine contino we now know a
woman has come forward she wants to
remain anonymous though i talked with
her on the phone and she's giving
cantino about 81 hundred dollars she
tells me she's a retired metro employee
and she wants to just help continue out
of the goodness of her heart there's
also the gofundme which you mentioned
more than 4100
raised there once she gets all of the
money i talked with the landlord he says
that uh she will likely no longer be
homeless and he'll let her back in there
again that is thanks to our viewers one
viewer more than 8 000. absolutely
amazing vanessa thanks for the update